but of course before we go we're gonna
leave you with some good vibes courtesy
of dakota johnson uh yeah while
appearing on the tonight show with jimmy
fallon dakota revealed that she is in
fact a wedding crasher and that she
attended a stranger's italian nuptials
after her friend told her to meet her
there and after several glasses of wine
take it easy
i heard yes i heard that you like
i heard that you'd like to crash
weddings and i just think that's
interesting
that is interesting
um it's interesting you say that i did
that once
wait you don't like that's not a thing
that you do well a friend of mine we
were in the same place and i was like i
was in italy with my sisters and
in italy they have they have a lot of
wine
there
and
so that was your invite right there huh
so that they
my friend was at this wedding and he was
like just come it's a really big wedding
no one will know and then
all of a sudden i'm just making eye
contact with the bride as she's being
bounced in a chair
and she was like
it's pretty fun why is she here that's
cool though dakota johnson's at my
wedding
i'm a nice person to
i know you are yeah but i mean but so
that's i thought i'm sorry i thought
there was a story that you crashed
weddings crashed parties no well i the
other night in
here actually i was just at dinner with
friends and they were like we're going
to birthday party electric lady
so i went to that um and you you weren't
really invited to that either no
no it wasn't but it actually wasn't even
a birthday party it was a staff party
that's even crazier but then but then so
maybe they were really like what are you
doing here
well maybe you do crash things and you
don't think about it
is there any other
examples
was i invited to this show oh my
goodness you're
you are always invited to this show we
love you